hello everyone and welcome to today's
presentation titled modeling
inflammation and fibrosis and humans
with PSC derived steatohepatitis liver
organoids presented by Takanori - cafe
associate director of the center for
stem-cell and organized medicine and
professor at Cincinnati Children's
Hospital as well as professor at Tokyo
medical and dental University and
professor and principal investigator at
Yokohama City University my name is mark
Kennedy of thermo Fisher Scientific and
I'll be your moderator for today's
presentation so before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting any questions
you may have at any time during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your question into
the drop down box that appears on the
screen we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation so if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please use the ask a question box to let
us know of any technical technical
difficulties so with that please allow
me to introduce dr. - Kevin so dr. -
cafe is an associate director of the
Center for stem-cell and organized
medicine also known as custom at the
Cincinnati Children's Hospital Medical
Center and as I mentioned he's also
professor at Yokohama City University
and Tokyo medical and dental University
of Japan he serves as on the board of
directors at the International Society
of stem cell research and his lab
investigates the mechanisms of human
organogenesis and he developed many
organoid or many organ technologies from
human stem cells namely organ bud based
approaches he is applying IPSC liver
buds into drug discovery as well as
transplant applications for patients
with a rare congenital metabolic
disorder ultimately expanding the
clinical indications to diseases like
liver cirrhosis and with that i'd like
to thank dr. Jacoby for joining us and I
will now turn the presentation over to
him
thank you so much for the kind of
introduction and good good evening I
think to everyone and I'm in Japan and
good morning from Japan and my name is
taka taka Bay and thank you so much for
some Fisher members for giving me this
really high-tech opportunity to present
our list of works related to organoid so
I just rightly modified my presentation
title so the ear of organic medicine to
cover the more broader perspective of
what we are working on using the human
proponents themselves all right so I
just a little bit about great thanks to
my members in the different labs so I'm
currently learning five different rubber
trees in Cincinnati Children's and
Oklahoma City University in the middle
and akhator a joint program in a
together pharmaceutical and Design
Center which is a little different from
my talk and also toka medical dental
University especially I like to
appreciate doctor Taniguchi who is also
the professor at the Oklahoma City
University and we are working very
closely for the translational
application over a liberal organic based
approaches and also I'd like to thank
for the funding agencies including that
aim at jst jsps and nice F indicator for
Masuda goal as well and also
collaborator as well so I'm working in a
Cincinnati Children's AB custom and I am
really grateful for the tremendous
support from the custom faculty members
at Cincinnati Children's and also she
Yamanaka working at the color University
is providing us the the fantastic stem
cell source which is namely an idea
cells for the translational applications
and with that I'd like to start my
presentation so just as the radio
background so I'm regionally interested
in transparent sergeant Kajri especially
for the liver transplantation so so this
is the first patient I actually met in
the United States when I was taking the
internship
Columbia University so as I said here is
how us but their patient I met there who
are Japanese patients who is mr. Asano
and he was very sort of lucky guy
because he was diagnosed as the very
severe liver failure back in Japan but
unfortunately there are very limited
number of transplants in Japan because
of probably because of limited
conscience so his only option was to fry
outside Japan to get a whole liver
transplantation meaning elsewhere
outside Japan and he was just lying into
the Columbia University and finally be
able to be transplanted by the whole
liver transplant approaches and now he
is completely coming from the disease
and back in Japan and working at their
elementary school teachers house before
so he was very lucky to be transplanted
but but I think behind the scenes I
think we are missing the very severe
statistics like this one so this is the
study statistics from the United States
and for the transplantations so as you
see from the blue bar and starting from
the early 1990s and the demand or
waiting patients for the whole organ
transplantation is growing over time
very intensively but in contrast natural
transplant case indicate by Greenberg a
remains stable which simply suggested
that the gap is growing and almost
hundreds of thousands of patients are
just waiting to die so this is really
catastrophic and very sad so I decided
to jump into the different field which
is namely a stem cell and organ or you
to to make a difference for the the
patients are waiting for the
transplantation so so so to do that we
are very interested in the organ I
technologies so this right
just show you the review papers
published by nature authored by the
cassandra and back in 2015 and as you
see here there are a number of different
dongle organoid technologies are coming
out for the past few years including the
Blaine organoid and we were all denied
and gastric organoid and in so forth and
you know the dr. society working at the
RIKEN is I think the one of the founder
for disputed by publishing a paper for
the optic cup organoid paper and also
hans krebs lab and dr. Toschi Sato is
developing a method for developing a
gastric organoid from the adult stem
cell populations followed by many
outstanding investigators in the world
to develop multiple different organs I
just wondered the beauty the background
of the variation of the organ or field
in the next right so organelle is
initially defined in early 90s and
growing steadily over time but for the
past few years the number of
publications for organ on is growing
intensely as in the slide so I think
throughout the the abrasion process I
think very lovely summarizing I think
there are many three major contributing
technologies driving the organized
evolution field so for instance if you
could be organized 1.0 version one I
think this is the initial of foundation
of the orgonite acknowledges so dr.
Wilson is working with the sea sponge a
sea animals and found that if you
dissociated the sea sponge into the
single cells and reallocating them in a
small well you found the the entire
system structures can be reformed by the
v a gregarious ecologies so so I think
the aggregation
found in the early 90s is clearly a very
important
technologies to to look at the
self-organization potential which is a
critical aspects for making organoid but
afterwards it turns out the more higher
animals like lawn and models or monkey
model I think still it's very
challenging to make an old and I from
Justin aggregate and to tackle death
I mean of the soul and other higher
nearing scientists using the ramming in
which extracellular matrix component or
in general are known as materials is
really important for for enabling the
self-organization into Illinois so
combining with the lis aggregate with
material so loving in with GCM she and
many of the investigators found out we
even for the dilaudid model we can make
an organized including the memory
organoid or CUNY argan oil and organize
another version 3 I think this is the
major driver for the organ I are
increasing organ fabrication is the
human stem cell or technologies
including the adult stem cells include
potent stem cells including the
embryonic stem cells or iPS cells so
having that adult stem cell source or
apple potent stem cell source
dr. society and dr. creepers found out
the methods to make a human specific
organ oil and this was followed by a
series of investigators including Jim
wells in dr. Taniguchi in dr. Norwich in
machine Okamura Marissa little to make
her
gutful deny or okay no Laura organoid or
our brain and so forth but today I'm
going to really focusing on the future
of organ which I think the organ of
medicine or application of organize for
the medical applications so so for the
past three version of organization was
merely driven by be the method to make
an oval but but it turns out we are now
able to make a sort of humor miniature
version of organ so I think we
for the future I think I'm really
interested in the promise of application
of organ into the medical miracle fuel
to accelerate this process at Cincinnati
Children's
we are recently establish our new center
called custom center for stem-cell on
organic medicine so all odds on who is a
noted developmental biologist in a
liberal field
what land field is a difference is a
director for the custom and code
directed by Jim James wells in Mike
Hellmuth and myself
Angie wells is working on a number of GI
organoid including in gastric or
intestinal or ROG intestinal organ as
well and Michaelmas is our surgeon in
clinician scientists in developing a
method to transplant the intestinal
orgonite to model the human development
in people so so we are establishing a
very critical infrastructures to
increase the access to the organ or
technologies including the core
laboratories including a gene editing
core or imaging quarter or or
epigenetics core and so forth and to
help the creation scientist to use the
very high-tech approaches for the the
the organ research and also we are
developing a blanket ILP which enables
the the the collection of the human iPS
cells or eventual way to develop
organoid as a banking strategies from
the layer disease patients as well as
healthy kid patient populations and also
we are developing accelerator level
trees which is I think very unique
infrastructures to enable the
interaction between the academia and
industry so we are welcoming the
industry scientists with a close
proximity to our academic laboratories
to be able to for instance screening VD
drugs in our organic system for the
commercial prototyping and also we have
the
Kuniko gray a GMP laboratory for the
tissue processing processing in a
clinical level so these sort of four
major our accent later components is
helping the scientist to to to use the
orgonite for the medical applications
and and we are actually dividing the
four different phases for the eventual
development organic matter so always I
think the important thing is the the
basic science part so we are studying
that human development and motoring the
development in vitro or we can make make
a new complex organ structures so we
have still many challenges which I am
going to keep going to highlight in the
latest right so we still create needs
basic science components as a major
driver but I think equally important the
prototyping of a second phase is also
important so so for instance I think if
you use the Illinois for the drug
screening I think we need to show the
the positive evidence to predict the
human clinical trials and also negative
evidence to to predict the human
outcomes which for instance the drugs
are failed in the clinical studies has
been decapitated in a diseased organ
conditions and so I think we need to
show the total preliminary evidence for
the organoid based application of the
product prototyping stage and if you see
the very promising potential I think we
can move for move forward or move
further for the translation so so we are
currently working on the transplant
application of liver organize so we are
working with the large-scale production
protocols or larger animal model to test
the efficacy or safety in preclinical
conditions to treatment fourth and also
some of the commercial prototyping has a
potential for the industrial relations
so some case I think we are developing a
Serbs in some case we are licensing out
to the companies to facilitate the
commercial application Oberg annoyed for
for improving the accessibility for the
many scientists or clinicians to use
organic based approaches so I'm jumping
into the the basic science part which I
am learning in my laboratory in society
so the questions we are waking up
assessing our children is very simple so
how we can know the process of
organogenesis and how we model that
complex process by using the tumor stem
cell culture system so this is the top
question for you're still dealing base
so you know be the overall I think the
organ is really driven by the basic
developmental biology so I would say
translational and urology is really key
for the orgonite development so you know
the e gastrulation is the the whole the
initiation of the human development or
every develop an AMOLED evelopment and
afterwards we the tissues are specified
into the projective stage including the
endoderm or Exeter or mesoderm so we are
particularly interested in the forged
end loader which is diverse from the
early primitive endoderm structures so
forged endoderm is really giving rise to
a variety of different organs including
the thyroid itself on us in rank and so
first but we are specifically interested
in the border between the four got a big
gap and posterior fold and portion is
giving rise to the number of critical
organs for the metamerism including
liver tissues beery tissues or ventral
conquering population or those are
pancreas as well so so what we are
working on is using a human stem cells
to model the molecular raj x which is
identified the classical developmental
biology - - to leverage that in a sense
of culture model to develop a design
principles for the cabbage reading the
human ovum Genesis imitation so buckling
2013 we are usually focusing on the most
premium process of liberal but formation
or early beaver development so I will
leave up
is actually specified from the part of
Caesarea former chief so at this stage
of the the population is named hepatic
specified abnormal cells and this is
about e95 just before a 95 in the mouth
or one month of the gestation in
Shermans and hepatic specified and
themselves at this stage in
two-dimensional [ __ ] right structures
but but afterwards they are forming on
liver but structures which is really a
3d and very complex structures
interestingly these 2d to 3d transitions
is requiring the support by the
additional supporting witnesses
including endothelial cells and also the
mesenchymal populations which is really
found by the dr. Kendall at groups and
once this Reba bar is formed in 3d
conditions the blood perfusion is
initiated afterwards and this is really
critical for pushing the cells to be
more mature and finally developing and
complete mature functional liver tissue
structures so what we are hypothesizing
is quite simple so
can we model the 3d 3d transitions by
the cabbage waiting these may be a
different projector interruption in
vitro in cultured and if that is true
can we push the maturation of in vitro
to revive organ but in vivo by proposing
the the structure from the circulations
in bebo so so this is basically a two
step hypothesis so human iPS cells are
directly differentiated into the
multiple culture interest in mixed in uh
well to see if we can make our self or
when I stole them but in vitro and if we
can make it can we transplant into the
animal model to see if we can get a
maturity choosing in vivo so some thanks
right is simple or summary of what we
are working on initially so all working
with the human iPS cells on their feet
of we is provided by doctor Shinya
Yamanaka which is actually clinical
grade so or directly differentiated into
the three major winners in vitro I think
they are to the right I think we I'm
just showing we animation or movies for
the self-organization process but it's
not really coming up but anyway using
three different regions including the
transitional hepatic random population
primarily marked by the T big three in
septum mesenchyme population marked by
the WT one and primitive endothelial
cell population marked by ICD so d1 will
be eco hearing we are able to make her
three critical ingredients for the view
about formations and using that three
progenitor population we are able to
make us really miniature we robot
structures in vitro so the next write is
showing the structure of these are bit
relieved about Reich structures so in
this pictures are let is a human
in the do tools differentiate it from
the IPS cells and the green one is a
hepatic progenitor population made but
made by the human iPS cells and this is
not really just the simple cluster this
is aggregate you want to see a very
experienced but it's not so so they are
developing Network Reich structures from
the red marked endothelial cell
populations and aligned with these
beautiful of networks right structures
are we see the hepatic cells aligned in
a beautiful modern so this is a clearly
and no signs of self organizations so we
return these structures as vascular eyes
leave about organize made by a bit of 3d
culture system so we also characterized
by tissue sections or single-cell
analysis and so forth to confirm this
Russian cities livery close to the Beebo
liver right issues involving bebo but
you know we there are critical signs of
self-organization like professional
networks we are expecting these issues
can be transplanted in vivo so that next
right shows the beaver outcomes
so okay so this is the transplanted
liberal but issues and and this whitish
per is the about one centimeter in size
and this is day zero after two days or
three days entire part get reps which
really suggesting the cells not
perfusing the entire structures made by
the human iPS cells in the mouse of
immunodeficient background so once the
broth fusion is initiated after two or
three days or 48 hours well 72 hours the
blood vessels are remodeled over time to
form a more sophisticated purposes
fractures so the next ride is confirming
VD I've shown a professional network so
so in this way the the dextran may be a
green one or blue one is the proper
fusion in the mouse and red and green
are red and orange in the human cell
component so if you're doing up other
tissues
if it's coming on coke okay so so this
is the to the right these the human
ideas and do networks so so so this is
just a confirm entire vascular
structures for by the human cells or
human ideas cells but for future words
are Ishi ated by the mouse calculations
so I originally thought be the to the
right I think that has to be animations
for confirming the chimeric personal
information between the human vessels
and in mouse vessels but it's not coming
out so skipping into the next right
okay
I think there are animation as well
though so this is just to to show you
the transplant process of liver but all
done on into the animal model but it's
not coming up so I'm skipping this and
to the bottom this is a transparent
Lieber but
this is a number of limo bots are
transplanted onto the method 3
communications which is close to the
port or main and to the right this is
the cup of My Luck card and in the sham
group is as shown in here indicated by
Bluebird and after 30 days we most of
the nose is dying overtime after 30 days
but but if you transplant the human
liver by organ on our into this location
or resin to experimentations is rescuing
the the ribbon failure or which is
result indicated by red color so this
will be simply suggesting that the the
most of the surviving mouse are rescued
by the function of replacement by the
liver about transplantations and this is
a therapeutic prototype of the concept
of the developer gano transplantations
and but I think this approaches is
really I think a universal or
generalizable for the other tissue as
well so we are working on the other
tissue organ a model as well including
the gut tissues lung tissues kidney
tissues or cardiac or brain and also
diseased tissues like cancer so our 3d
culture approaches is in aving entire
our tissues to be pasteurized in vitro
and to form a 1 centimetre tissues in
vitro and if you transfer into the mouse
using the human cells again we are able
to pasteurize after 48 hours of
transplantation in this vessel solid
motor over time as well and I think one
of the most remarkable organ where the
kidney because I think Eenie has a very
tremendous or powerful potential for the
in vivo self organizations so this is
just a macroscopic confocal live imaging
analysis or for generated kidney but
transplant and green marks regime
mouse-kini cells and web marks 3d
prepare cells
mine as you see here in the middle I
think very small tiny global Rybak
structures are beautifully formed from
the scratch and this is really I think
remarkable aspects of the Ocampa
transplantation approaches and also we
are working on a pancreatic model as
well and as you see here to the left is
also the the movie for a time-lapse
movie for the contradict vascularized of
an inflammation process but again I
don't need to see any videos so I can
skip here down as well and this is the
the middle is the the macroscopic view
of the generated Pascal right
pancreatic islet and that can be
transplanted into the capsule of the
kidney and using that transplantation
model we are comparing the least reputed
potential against the luminal diabetes
model in amongst so to the bottom cover
my against survival curve showing the
lumina diabetes since we recibir because
after four or five days with the out
transplantation most of the mouse is
just dying but if you transform the
mouse primary I read indicated by
Bluebird this transplant approaches is
effective to some extent so almost 50% o
the mouse is recovering from the
Praveena diabetes if you transplant the
mouse I read but you know we I think I
read transplantation is very promising
and because of the promises actually
tested in human or clinics as well but
the problem is the pasteurization or Ali
engrossment so so I read transplantation
is locking the basket errs so if you
combine with our older bit based
approaches we are expecting that
transplant efficiency might be improved
and because of that indicated by red bar
the vascularized
I read transplantation using our own
blood culture approaches is really
improving the efficacy of I read
transplantations as indicated by a red
LED bird
they simply suggesting the a transplant
efficiency is really important for the
therapeutic potential against the
diabetes conditions so having that
product concept demonstrations we are
now working in primarily working on the
liver transplantation to leskew the
disease patients in the final part of my
basic science is I think the next very
big challenge in in all in our field so
currently Olga no scientist is just
looking at the single organ to generate
so in our case we are working on the
liberty generation from the scratch or
stem cells but I say I think the single
organ generation approach is quite
limited in terms of the longer our in
vitro maturation or longer in vivo
functionalization because if you have a
defect in the surrounding structures
like very portion or bile duct or or
pancreas I think we have liver failed
what we have damaged the liver tissues
in vivo in a clinical conditions so you
know the sort of interior oven
connections or all multi organ
connections might be I think the next
basic science challenge to to go forward
so so here Oh Oh Kawika working in my
laboratory in Cincinnati spearheaded
this problem so he's working on the more
complex organic model and he recently
found the deep so this is a reporter
human iPS lines leaving the human procs
Wong Jing's by rfp using this reporter
system he was able to for from the
posterior forget to make Nick ticks
ruptures including liver tissues as well
as a medial portion or duodenum portion
as well so so to the right this is the
whole Montevideo staining of the
products one which is a hepatic portion
and DVA
is the biliary portion so combined with
two colors we are able to ensure the
functional connection between the liver
on video tracks and also we have a
pancreatic - biliary connections as well
as the biliary - intestinal connection
as well so this is a microscopic view of
ramiro survived human organ oil as well
as the mouse wheel in people structures
which is closely resembling the human
ideas organoid based approaches so I
think this kind of proof-of-concept
approach is really important for looking
at the expanding the potential for other
organs as well like can you rate your
bladder connection to a central nervous
system to the paper'll number system
connections or a lung to airway
connections and so forth so I think this
is a sort of very important challenge to
go forward so this is just a basic
science borrow olive tree but now from
now I'm switching a little bit for the
translational applications namely and
Olga medicine so you don't be
Olga nor can be developed from a patient
specific stem cell so a healthy person
divides themselves
so using that tissues I think we can
study the human specific biology has a
basic science but more importantly I
think we can use dishes dishes as other
to the human disease conditions so
having that are better I think we are
able to monitor the disease progressions
or disease prevention or
disease treatment in vitro so so having
that approaches I think we can envision
the precision medicine application on
drug testing application in
pharmaceutical industries and ultimately
using a healthier stem cell organ I
think we can transfer back to the
patient to see if we can rescue the
disease conditions so we can we can
foresee a number of different
applications using our organic based
approaches in my lab particularly
interested in the liver organize so we
initially targeting the application to
the drug development process you know
the hepatotoxicity is a very bottleneck
or critical hurdles for the drug
development process especially in the
later stage of clinical trials if you
have some side effects related to the
liver toxicity I think this will be
causing a tremendous loss of the the
money and also the time for the
development so if you can predict the
hepatic toxicity in the human specific
condition I think that would be really a
tremendous for the drug development
process another phase to the next step I
think we can also use they're not just
our safety screening but also we can use
and tissue for the efficacy screening
cultures have started potatoes which is
growing medical problems for the number
of different countries and also we can
use the tissues for the new potentially
for the nutrition nutritional screening
for the Prevention's and also we can use
the extra Capri or device to be
integrated by the old annoyed to to to
use the tissues as a sort of supporting
device for the liver failure but as a
phase through your last phase I think we
can use a tissue for the transplant
patients we account retargeting the
congenital on the table Rica eller of
the the patients can be treated by organ
transplantations so i would focus on the
two main application in my talk the
first one is a drug efficacy screening
so as i said i think the stairs
toilets or non-alcoholic steppin Alice
is a really growing concern in many
different countries so in particularly
in the United States
I think Nash or set up italics is now
leading goals for the liver transplant
patients so clearly we need a high high
volume medical needs to be created by by
some medications but currently there are
no available surprisingly no available
effective drugs to treat the nash
conditions although they are estimated
to be opening up a huge market for for
the future drug industries I think this
is partly because we are locking our
effective human model - - - to the
caterpillar ate the center panel is
conditioning middle so we are hoping to
use organoid to model the nash
conditions in vitro so we SP are headed
this problem as well so initially we
have developed a message to make multi
cellular organelle or Oh
including the cantar innate immunity
population or macrophage population can
we co-developed in our liver all-women
conditions so so having the immune
components for she hypothesize to see if
we can recapitulate the entire process
of the distemper Tidus so set the
Politis is initially initiated upon the
hepatocytes lipid accumulation or name
reassess step ptosis but but if you get
the lipid accumulated over time I think
they are activating somehow the infantry
process triggered by the macrophage or
liver resident macrophage like Cooper
cell and after the informa tree stimuli
to continues I think the hepatocyte
is getting stressed out and the
cytoskeleton a disorganized and the
mitochondria are overloaded and
eventually developed by the fibrotic
population is expanded if we
to the photolysis so we exposed a number
of ingredient to trigger the statuses as
well as the information and the suit in
suit to see if we can make an fibrotic
condition in vitro by continued lipid
stimulation in vitro so so this is just
an basic hello my model we are currently
working on so we have I think this
should be also moving for an illiberal
information process so so we are
dividing we all got our model from the
human iPS cells to model the micron now
I'm not anatomy of the human liver
tissues so we have video ii
canonicalized structures which is a very
important folder by acid secretions and
we have by transporters polarized input
movement of the human labor organizer
and we have tight junction proteins as
well and this is really close to the
actual in vivo biochemical structure is
indicated by e/m analysis and having
that organizations I think we are able
to look at the by acid transport
visualized by the fluorescent bile acid
methyl based assays so we are able to
visualize by by lightly imaging to
monitor the bio acid excretion pathways
in our own level so this is a very I
think important for the multiple liberal
based applications and in this some kind
of model has a very unique advantage
because we have multicellular
configurations so the majority of cells
are composed by the human hepatocytes
indicated by the EP camp this is a
stereo cell markers so 80 percent
actually the hepatocytes but out of the
twenty percent
I think the half of the population these
are al see I am I'll come positive or CD
166 positive is still like cell lineages
which is amazing kind of cell population
residing in a nubuck issues and in into
the bottom I think more less minor
population but we do
we did produce ball or email one
positive Koopa rag cell population is
also called developed in these liberal
structures so to the right this is a
whole mountain you know stating or the
single liberal organoid and as you see
here majority is a EP camp or ecology we
nor c/ebp alpha positive have outside
populations but some of the assaulter by
mention concept mesenchymal cell
population responsible for eventual
fibrosis as well as the cd68 macrophage
population is call developed in this
liberal of known structures so having
that multicellular configurations index
are expose a pack or or carbohydrates a
metro to see if we can induce cell
houses so what is the left I think this
is also the live imaging pathology like
analysis in an organ level so if you
expose the fat or carbohydrates in a
higher level or we are able to show the
mass evacuation or try Chris Y indicated
by the green one in the bottom figure
and this is really those abandoned so if
you do not really modify the Culture
Media I think they never get any
triglyceride occupy anything but if you
increase the dose of fatty acid as well
as the carbohydrates we are able to
accumulate extensively into the liver
log on if you continue this lipid
accumulated conditions we are able to
show the preliminary fibrosis like a
phenotype in vitro so partner H is a
Muslim Frank are abstaining and after
seven days we see some collagen
depositions and then a panel I is also
the immunostaining of the whole mount
tissues analysis and green one is the
fibrotic population and lip one is like
30 other populations who combined I
think we see the fibrosis are fibroid
except population are propagated in our
older model
parallel jelly is a biochemical analysis
of the supernatant so so this is a
program in peptide which is also used in
the clinics to diagnose the fibrosis and
this biomarker is also increased in our
set but I dislike organ on Culture Media
so combined I think how organ is
probably able to model the preliminary
aspects of the static analysis or
fibrosis initiative specific conditions
how much predictive in this organic
model so to test that I think we are
using the general generic contribution
to be predicted in in an over model so
so to test that we are looking at the
three major volumes reported by others
publishing the Nature Genetics
bunkering 2017 last year so also using
these three major most significant
volumes we are stratifying or make a
better ranking of 25 hundreds of
genotype available since around and it
made our list ratifying panel so highly
patient stem cell rinds and middle risk
patient stem cell lines or minimally
school Louis Simpson right to see if we
can borrow that genetic conditions in a
selected couple of steps arranged into
the right this is a triglyceride
staining you know Overland level using
the different risk patient populations
and as you see here high risk patient
stem cell organoid is accumulating we
try chrysolite much higher extent than
the middle risks themselves were all
these custom cell derived hold on i'm so
this really is simply suggesting that
genetic factors identified by the
hundred thousands of our patient
genotype knowledge can be predicted by
the couple would different stem cell
right analysis in older level so this is
I think very remarkable to predict the
phenotype in a
two months using the kebab Simpson right
so so having that collaboration in the
humans we now test the critical are
trials like mission in vitro using the
kind retesting compounds Michael very
colic acid as well as f0 nineteen so to
the left this is like pickasee analysis
like copper mining a survival curve and
but this is an organized survival curve
so so if you look at the ha blue or
light blue bar this is a known drug
traded condition so this is like a sham
group so organelle is eventually dying
off over time but if you expose the
ovary colon cassette or FC of 19 which
is remarkably improving the survival
after the ptosis TV right as we answer
indicated by the pink as well as dark
gray and if you do not really expose the
fat I think they are surviving all the
time so this really are highlighting the
organoid base of survival outcomes these
are somehow familiar to the clinical
trials testing contain 3/4 Nash but not
just for the efficacy like analysis I
think we can use their surviving organ
for the father mechanistic studies so
for instance this is comparing the
reactive oxygen species which is also
the trigger for the increment 3 crosses
in a bottle sites so so we see the
massive information of reactive oxygen
species in fact reading Illinois but
that can be a improved or decreased by
the oh very cool Agassi treatment or
6:19 treatment as well and this is the
quantitative analysis and also I'm not
going to go into detail because of the
time limitations but but fibrosis can be
predicted by the stiffness measurements
parole annoyed if you look at the start
of pathologies overnight the untreated
one is very low but if you increase the
fibrosis night conditions in organoid
the stiffness is really highly
up regretted as indicated by the blue
bar but but that stiffness increase can
be also turns out or you hitted by the
extremes nineteen or also Alberta colic
acid so this is really it's just ink or
highlighting that potential for the
clinical trials like condition in the
dish so by multiplying the genetic
factors as well as lifestyle fractures
or screening factors we are able to
conduct human organ oil based trials or
hope trials which we think for the
efficacy screening in vitro in the
future and we also develop in the higher
who put for for measuring the stiffness
measurements which is not really showing
up here and also we are working on the
sort of fall digital solution to be
degraded to to monitor donor in a y OS
manner and so forth but anyway we are
expecting in the future although no
trials can be very meaningful to for the
clinical trials and as a last part of my
presentation is focused in a phase three
application which is namely a
transplantations so i think old annoying
or over but transplantation is sort of
intermediate approaches between
currently preparing old and transplant
as well as the hepatocytes also wall
transplantation so this is the orgonite
transplanted transplantations what we
want to prove is to make a functional
alga by transplanting very immature
tissues or very immature organize to see
if we can eventually let's get the metal
clipper disease so i think there are a
couple reading this relative working on
uh transplantations
I think Tokyo Medical Dental University
which is also my second affiliation and
but not my group but different group is
also working on the transplantation or
will whole annoyed initially targeting
of the inflammatory bowel disease using
adult stem cell on annoying and also the
nether run for European group or our
group or Sentinel Children's is also
working on the older transplantation
application for trading weakening
proximal disease so I think in the next
ride is just a simple bill or what we
want to do in the future
this is quite
so Olga my manufacturing and transplant
into the patient's hopefully transplant
event or within a couple years so this
is simple but I think it's really
challenging because number of different
components for organelle production has
to be supported by the industry partners
because I think we need to have critical
green media we have to have clinical
grade culture parades well we have to
develop clinical predicting the
preclinical animal model or the small
loader model or sometimes incurring the
large animal model as well and we have
to develop critical valuation protocols
by microscopic analysis as well as other
biochemical assays and probably we
somehow need a robotic support for
scaling up the process so so this is
really I think very challenging and too
too much for the academic sign this so
we need a collaborative networks by
working with the number of different
industry partners to do that so I'm just
showing a couple different example of
the collaboration with the companies so
so this is the the our mass production
platform by collaborating with Z with
the chemical companies called a cool
alight so we have developed a critical
gray a micro well pray which is already
well one well la pray form where we very
we have the 20,000 micro wells are
placed over the well praise and we can
make a very homogenous beautiful or
miniature organized structures in a
single culture time and to the right
this is the collective human liberal
Illinois from the purple stem cell just
showing you the homogeneous tissue can
before in a very large-scale manner so
we have the mass production platform and
also be raking on the robotic companies
to make GMP manufacturing facilities so
this Airport was primarily ended by dr.
Taniguchi working in a compensating
University in collaboration with my
level 3 and I do
I think this also the movie but but we
have the robotic automatic machines to
make our hundred so for our organ can be
manufactured in a continuous manner in
isolated manner which is a clinical
grade so having that collaborations we
are hoping to transfer back to the
patients within the next few years by
initially targeting the US cycle
disorders so so for this particular
application we are using the human iPS
cells provided by the coder University I
think as you already aware but dr. June
Takahashi at Kyoto University initiated
the clinical trials using this
particular IPS run for the pockets of
disease last week actually this is very
a quite exciting but using the same IPS
mind they are using we are also
preparing for the clinical trials for
the liver disease by developing a GMP
grade manufacturing process and
transmitted back to the patients to see
if we can improve the clinical outcomes
so so within the arbitrary indications I
think we have tremendous demands so as I
highlight it in a background right
we have over four thousands of patients
on just dying during the waiting period
for the liver transplantation and but
this is really underestimated I think
and also we have multiple different
countries waiting for the liver
transplantation so I think I think to
fair to be fair I think currently
overall 68 over almost hundred thousands
of the patients are waiting to die for
the liver transplantation so I think
this patient population can be obviously
the indication for even for the
challenging organization approaches but
within this sort of absolute indication
thinking we can open up a very large
promising market for the pure creature
commercialization so so this is just a
summary of my talk and I think in the
future I think we can transfer back to
the patient especially in a very end
stage or a very chaotic or
organ failure conditions which we can
certainly transplant organized into the
patients but I think organ
transplantation or so W product is
really expensive so I think we need to
narrow down the indications to really
specifically targeting the patients who
can not really created by other
modalities but I think majority of the
patients is benefited by the precision
medicine applications on drug treatment
so I think organ is green and meaningful
to still for drug screening or precision
type of applications so this is a just a
sort of overall big picture of what we
are predicting in your future by using
old medicine applications with that I'd
like to thank all my members in the
laboratories as well as the
collaborators and thank you so much for
your attention and happy to take some
questions
you
few doctors can be for that really
amazing presentation so will now begin
the live question-and-answer portion of
this webinar so I'd like to remind you
again if you do have a question that
you'd like to ask please do so now by
clicking on the ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
in the box that appears on your screen
and then just click the send button so
with that let's get started so back to
the cavity we we do have a few questions
here one of the questions that has come
in is what do you think are the
technologies that will be driving your
organoid 4.0
you
okay so you were asking about this
question number two
question number eight number eight okay
technologies will be driving over a full
point at all so I think I think I think
it's it's there are a couple differences
depending on the application so for
instance I think drug screening
application I think technologies we are
lacking is the sort of higher throughput
screening system so so for instance I
think in our organ or part of using the
live imaging approaches or live
stiffness measuring approaches to
predict a certain varieties conditions
but I think still I think the throughput
is limited to two tests I think at best
I think we can test the hundreds of
compounds in organ level but in a real
world or in a your drug screening
companies I think they are testing over
hundreds of thousands of compounds in a
cell line model so we need to increase
the throughput extensively so for the
particular drug screening application I
think we what we are lacking or what we
need is for the higher throughput
instruments to measure the the organized
needles in a higher speed so that with
that I think we are collaborating with
the solo flower micro robotics scientist
or micro fluidics scientist to to make
our make this happen so so I think
depending on applications but
particularly for the drug screening I
think we microfluidic type of
application is really important but up
for the transform brackish transplant
application is really different so so
transplantation is really critically
driven by the I think the mass
production in a clinical grade so just
making them tissues in a larger scale is
quite easy
I think but but in a critical grade
manufacturing process is I think really
challenging because we need a validation
protocols or and also we have to
manufacture in a very clean or very
critical grade and facilities to to make
sure they are pretty safe and and also
we need to tell
solo be mass-produced tissues in the
animal model to confirm the safety to
make sure we do not really develop a
tumors or uncontrollable or cancer liked
issues in beeble so clinical grade
manufacturing or mass production is
really critical technologies we are
still dealing with for the transplant
application so it's really depending on
the application but I think there are a
couple of key hurdles still existing and
how far away do you think that kind of
technology is is this something you
think we'll see in the next couple of
years another five to ten years so yes
we are we are actually planning to
transfer and within three years from now
so we are almost in the final process of
the manufacturing process as well as the
valuation process so currently we are
planning on the safety trials with the
period because it's with the aim of
obtaining the efficacy signals Prakriti
advocacy analysis we are planning on the
twenty twenty or twenty twenty-one to be
initiated so it's not really for our
future and for the precision medicine I
think as you already know the cystic
fibrosis application is already
initiated in a Han screamers group in
another run so so they're using the
organization's for model or predict the
human condition Meena cystic fibrosis to
derive organ on and they are actually
selecting the effective drugs and now
treat it by the drugs selected by the
whole narrow so for the procedural
medicine I think it's already happening
so so it's not really far future I think
it's a very tangible feature thanks for
that and it's actually kind of good
segue to one of the other questions that
is here as it relates to adult tissue
derives organize models as you know some
of the other models that are out there
there's an adult tissue derived liver
organized model as well perhaps you
could compare your model with that model
what you think the sort of the
advantages and disadvantages are of the
existing models today
thank you so much I think this is very
important so I think we have good and
bad so for the IPS or ESL divine Morgana
model has a advantage for the bounty
cellular configuration so I think mostly
the adult tissues revival going on is a
theory all cell structures so we have a
couple of cell types but mostly I
ethereal cell types but IPS or es cell
based approach we are able to co-develop
supportive regions including the
mesenchymal components and also immune
components and in condition to that we
have ethereal components so multi
cellular configuration is I think
important but downside of organoid from
the IPS or PSC is the I think modulation
stage so you know the adult stem cell is
a doubt device but IPS or yourself is is
from the the ingress or or egg station
so it's really freaked out Fito an
embryonic stage for functionality of the
e IPS or PSC model is a little bit
immature or completely less mature than
adult stem cell organoid so for the drug
screening application or some of the
organ functions is a little difficult to
you to predicting a PSC base model but
can do with the adult stem cell all in a
model but interestingly I think for the
transplantation
I think the adult is to divide this a
little difficult and grafting video
probably because of the lack of
supporting components and probably
because the immaturity is really
important for the eventual
enrollment so so I think well for the
transplant application we are
intentionally using the immature or less
mature
organized tissues for the
transplantation to improve the beaver
outcomes so it's there are many still
arguable points for the aps-c divisor or
adult stem cell derived Organa model but
each has a different advantage for the
different applications
I think we have time for for just
another question here so a question that
this just came in is asking regarding
transplantation into liver disease
patients have you estimated just how
many organized you would actually need
to transplant to have a therapeutic
benefit
thank you so much so so here we we are
running cheap run strength over I think
100 thousands of organoid for patients
with the congenital disease for the kids
so which is equivalent to the 10 to the
8th or or less than 10 to the 9 cell or
number equilibrant hypersonically brain
so this number is actually determined by
the previous clinical trials of the
primary hepatocytes transplantation
actually implemented in the clinics so
for the hepatocytes plantation I think
the in the clinics the physicians are
transplanting over 10 to the 8th
hepatocytes into the patient and they'll
let me see the benefit from that disease
are conditions so so we are probably
initially planning to transfer the
equipment number of the parasite
transplantation which is about hundreds
of thousands of organoid to three decent
clinical trials thank you so much for
asking the questions that is a lot of
organized yeah it's a lot so so with
that we'll we'll bring this webinar to a
close once again I'd like to thank dr.
took heavy for his Israeli excellent
presentation here and before we go
please note that today's webinar will be
available for on-demand viewing through
February 2019 and thank you all for
joining us and we hope you enjoy the
rest of today's event
thank you so much bye-bye